I’m Keerti and I’m representing Octathorpe.
Our game “Hitwicket Superstar”
is a unique strategy-based cricket game
where the user is the owner of a team.
After we came back from the indie games accelerator,
we’ve successfully migrated our entire server
to the Google’s cloud platform.
We started using the firebase tool
for conducting several AB tests,
trying to know our users deeper,
their behaviour, their patterns.
I think the program has really helped us
improve on a lot of fronts,
be it in terns of tech, data analysis,
predicting user’s behaviour,
and implementing some really interesting
gameplay concepts.
There has been an excellent network of mentors,
fellow developers and the Play Store team
to help you get all the help, support
and guidance that you would need
in making your game.